so after getting the second dose of the
cobit 19 vaccine can we
live our lives normally again orco mana
spoke to some experts tonight and joins
us now live from the las vegas
convention center with what they had to
say orco
well denise that's the million-dollar
question what can we do
after we are fully vaccinated experts
say until
more nevadans come to sites like the
convention center here to get the second
dose
we should still keep practicing the
basics
it is a sense of relief stuart timpa
just got his second dose of the covet 19
vaccine he says the line at the
convention center site thursday was long
but well worth it
i definitely feel more protected
against kopet but timpa knows we're not
quite out of the woods yet
we still have to remain vigilant and
cautious and
you know keep ourselves protected and
you know as
well as protecting everyone else
infectious disease epidemiologist brian
labis says it takes about two weeks for
the second dose to fully kick in
but there's still a small chance people
can get infected with the virus
even after getting the vaccine gives you
good protection
but not complete protection it's kind of
like when you have airbags in your car
you still wear your seatbelt
you still have to go back and do those
other things unfortunately
you can't just give up on everything
we've done in the past that means mask
wearing and social distancing are here
to stay for now
experts say about 70 percent of people
need to be fully vaccinated in order to
reach a sense of hurt immunity
we are on track to be able to get um to
that point really by
you know end of summer beginning of fall
for sure i think we will be able to
gather
safely with each other for thanksgiving
and for christmas
until then timpa has one message for
nevadans you have to keep your guard up
and
you can't get relaxed
experts add that in order to get back to
normal faster
it will be crucial to convince people
who are hesitant about the vaccine
to get vaccinated reporting live from
the las vegas convention center tonight
orca mana 8 news now